morning mr mayor now you aren't
responsible for the metropolitan police
but but you pointed out yesterday
that you took action to change
the leadership in manchester uh when you
thought they weren't doing their job
harriet harmon says that cressida dick
has to go because she can't inspire
trust kia stammer says she should stay
is harriet right or kia
so
it's very difficult for me to comment on
that trevor because as you pointed out i
do have the formal responsibility
of assessing the performance of a chief
constable and where necessary uh making
a change which i did
late last year so you know if i were to
pass comment on this situation obviously
it has some wider resonance uh than me
just being you know giving an
off-the-cuff view and because i don't
have you know the inside information i
to be honest i'm not going to to pass a
sort of knee-jerk a knee-jerk view
the only thing i would say is obviously
this is the most senior policing
position in the land we have a woman in
that in that role
i would say that should give some
confidence that from here a convincing
strategy can emerge from the met but
more broadly to tackle violence against
women and girls
well you say that
but a former chief constable sue fish
who ran nottinghamshire i was just
talking to
the conservative party chairman about
what she said
one of the other things that she said in
an interview yesterday was that
when she tried to draw attention to some
of these issues she was denigrated
isolated and marginalized by many senior
people including and she names her
crested dick now
of course you can't make a a judgment
but do you think
that given what is now being said and
the issue of confidence do you think it
is reasonable
for londoners to feel that
crested dick is the right person to
solve the problem that have occurred on
her watch given your experience in
manchester
oh it's certainly reasonable for the
question to be asked and for the debate
to be had uh of course that's the case
uh trevor but you know it wouldn't be
right for the mayor of greater
manchester
to be telling the mayor of london uh or
indeed londoners who should run the
metropolitan police i i will if you
don't mind leave that question to them
what i would say is some of the
statements that came out from the met
over the weekend felt like they were
going down the wrong track you know
women should wave down a bus any answer
to this uh issue that begins with the
words women should or women must is in
my view the wrong answer this is an
issue that starts with men
and boys and that is where attention
should go
and i would say all of us actually need
to start building from that from that uh
that starting point i am going to lead
personally
a high-profile public education campaign
in greater manchester aimed at men and
boys which will talk about how our
behavior can make women feel uh when
perhaps they're out late at night on
public transport or walking in a in a
dark street i think we need to take this
much more seriously i i speak to my
teenage daughters my youngest daughter
the other day says you know wolf
whistling is just kind of routine and
but it has an impact and and how can
that be right you know 40 year old men
wolf whistling 16 year old girls that
kind of thing
people should be embarrassed to to do
that that kind of thing has to be called
out and actually trevor other men have
to call it out against friends who do it
and this is the kind of conversation i
think we now need to have about this
issue
rather than lurching to knee-jerk
solutions that might you know please a
headline in a newspaper but not actually
provide a solution
indeed and you've you've pointed out
this is not just a london or a met
problem
what happened here in manchester
after the manchester arena bombing
was a real
renewed focus on counter-terrorism
some people have been saying that
actually we need that level of focus on
the question of violence against women
and girls would you support the proposal
that i think has been come forward today
that there should be a prevent program
diversion interception
identification of likely offenders there
should be a prevent programme that
focuses on violence against women and
girls that is as resourced and as
uh significant as the one that we've
used against islam islamist terrorism
so i probably wouldn't call it that in
terms of a prevent program or you know
make the com direct correlation with
terrorism but if you're saying there's a
need for a national programme where this
is taken much more seriously and all
police forces in england and wales are
required
to make this a a high priority which it
would seem the government is currently
resisting then yes i would absolutely
say say yes to that because i do think
this needs sustained effort on every
single level
at the front door of the police station
in terms of how police treat victims the
training for police officers but that
broader public engine education campaign
i was talking about a moment ago so
absolutely to a yes to a national
resource program that kind of takes this
whole issue into a completely different
space with regard to the focus that it
gets and for me that is what was coming
out after the appalling murder of sarah
everard that was the call coming from
women and girls right across the country
and it has to be heard trevor i think
there's a danger of words not deeds here
and i think we need the opposite we need
to see action uh against uh violence
against women and girls in the aftermath
of sarah's murder i brought forward the
conversation on the strategy
to tackle this issue here in greater
manchester and we've just passed our
strategy uh in just the last week so we
are taking it seriously but i would only
support a national program i'd like uh
to to give further i'd like to i'd like
to get on
i'd like to get on to leveling up very
quickly but very briefly
would you support
an independent inquiry into the vetting
procedures which
applies to all uh constabularies because
we've now learnt
that this man cousins could even now
have got through the vetting procedures
that gave him a uniform and a warrant
card
yes in a word i i would i think that
does need to be to be looked at and i
also think there needs to be an inquiry
into the the broader culture uh within
police forces and we're certainly doing
that here in great events because we've
acknowledged the culture in our own
police force hasn't been right but
perhaps some of those subcultures uh
within uh within police forces those
closed uh those closed whatsapp
groups so i think all of this is where
we need to go perhaps as part of that
that national drive that you you were
pointing to i think what is indisputable
is that this issue needs to to move up
uh several several runs up the ladder in
terms of the prioritization and you know
that that much is is unarguable i would
say trevor
okay
you and the um other big city mayors met
the prime minister this week
you now have a new secretary of state
for leveling up in the shape of michael
go if you'd had your choice um
would it have been michael gove
you know i think it probably would
uh given given
the choice of ministers around
because
while i don't always agree with him
michael does bring
real energy to what he does intellect
uh and i would expect that leveling up
won't remain
undefined for much longer now michael is
in charge of debris so i actually think
it was good news
for for levelling up we we haven't met
the prime minister actually we we met
michael last week and had a very good
conversation with him and as the
conservatives come to manchester for
their conference i'm not going to rerun
the arguments of 2020 we're still sure
if we're honest about about that the
pandemic has hit us really hard but i
don't think it would get the people here
anywhere so what i'm saying to michael
gove and the prime minister as they
arrive here in manchester is here is a
big positive offer from us let us help
you define leveling up and let us help
you deliver leveling up and in our case
that means a london style public
transport system for greater monster
crucially with london level fares where
it's one pound 55
to catch a bus uh compared to the four
pounds or more that people have to pay
here
can i just put this to you uh you've
made this transport plan the the center
piece of your uh proposals for leveling
up um can't tell you what i think
they're saying in well i know because
they said it to me in rochdale and
oldham and bolton there's all very well
but this is just andy's plan
uh to allow us
to have to to travel into manchester
central but actually none of this is
going to help uh the really uh depressed
parts of greater manchester who are the
rochdales uh and the old arms and to
some extent boltons you can name them
yourselves but actually this is really a
city center mayor
mayor at work rather than a mayor for
the whole of manchester
no
that isn't the case i can understand why
people say that but but trevor this
system that i'm talking about would
would be for all 2.8 million residents
of greater manchester and it would
better to connect them to jobs and
opportunities in their own boroughs but
also uh further afield and you know this
place i'm talking to now it's salford
it's very hard to get from rochdale or
oldham to media city uh so it would help
connect people to jobs in any part of
greater manchester but the critical
thing is this actually we're already
beginning to see how a strong city
centre lifts the towns outside of it
stockport has a mayoral development
corporation where there are plans for
3500 homes and i would like to bring one
to middleton uh in the borough of of
rochdale just between uh you know on the
fringes of manchester we think this plan
will help lift the proud
mill towns of of greater manchester
particularly those across the north and
so it's about town and city rising
together and we think we've got evidence
to show that